dural if you really want to assure
conservative Catholics that you're
holding the line on gay marriage don't
pose like you're on top of a gay wedding
cake they will stop acting like this
viral video of the rat making off with
an entire slice of pizza is cute I could
have been a meal for a homeless person
and for dessert he could have had the
pizza
new role of cab driver is a serious
about competing with uber they should
start by getting rid of these things
this isn't really an air freshener it's
more a sign that says my air
conditioners broken okay I have no idea
how to get to your destination and my
radio is blaring Pakistani disco hero
the next politician who says he wants to
restore America to how it used to be has
to go to the beach without sunscreen and
sit there all day running his toes
through cigarette bus touchy crowd new
rules since America loves Pope Francis
and Hillary Clinton needs a boost she
should start wearing a 2-foot hat
and call herself the other leader who
gave up having sex for power
you